yeah welcome to this video I'll be doing
some sorry let's keep it thing again and
we've got them on the white side again
the slightly mysterious player
Igor Goro EF who has been labeled so to
say as being morozova John some what's
our website and yeah in fact there is
some evidence pointing to this some
openings that that he's playing and also
yeah sometimes you can deduct a little
bit of things about the online times
when a player's online so probably they
are not online if they play a tournament
and so on alright so we've got five
minute game going here and I'll just
assume that this is really a rossovich
on the white side his um been very quick
here 30 seconds spent only against um
grandmaster from Hungary and I know who
this is but I just forgot it
Sultan made VG um not quite sure he's
higher very high rated medvirginia not
quite sure about two things to 600 or
even more natural so okay what's
happening here
white white Scott white is a pawn down
but he's got two bishops and he's got
this somewhat weird Queen King side
it was g4 g5 so he some expanded and
it's not a weakness really it's um an
asset those icons can be used to drive
from blacks pieces back especially this
bishop only five so white um probably
has at least some compensation oh well
well does this Bishop go now Bishop a5
does before
so probably bishops III was a mistake
but I'm only I'm just adjusting to this
game it's not so so easy here's a double
attack on the night and on c5 was check
and yeah you should be one is hanging so
black yes sir just just curtains
yeah very quick women in terms of time
spent under under a minute so very very
quickly played yeah played this tactic
who's gone yeah boy if I don't think I
played oh let's say Rosa [ __ ] I didn't
didn't flame on with this hand I think I
played him years ago when he was on with
different handles but only one or two
games and they probably lost yeah he had
always very tough looks fights with with
grief joke ended at the top
GM's but then for while he in online
chess young deaths he went under the
radar I guess I'm not sure which handily
played on probably this is really him so
very much possible yeah one unfortunate
thing is that he's always taking a bit
of time between games so it's not a
steady flow of games one after another
I'd like to check out if there's
something something else some going here
going on here
yeah I keep I keep him on the follow
list but in the meantime we can look at
something here this is again this
grandmaster from Hungary playing
some GM from us that integrator I'm not
sure if I know this guy it's got no name
in them 2600 is some quite quite high
yeah we got them pretty uncommon opening
here it was the tirage defense with wide
playing and the early D takes e5 and
this certainly should be fine for black
hard to believe that white should have
anything these kind of positions are not
not so easy to assess sometimes what I
mean with this kind of positions is with
the pawn on d5 this kind of stuff it's
simply we can see five so black gets the
knight on c5 for instance Knight be
three years on maybe the right movie I
don't know about Knight cv3 Quincy 3 can
be tricky tween a Knights b3 Quincy 3
rook takes a 1 and then night night
somewhere I'm a black and play f6 first
my beam we are positionally this kind of
these kind of structures with b5 and
InDesign always tricky because white is
got ideas of putting a piece on c6 from
the black has a good night on c5 which
now really picks up the exchange
yeah black is an exchange up it's not
not clear what what the compensation
should be with the f6 black has stopped
anything on the long diagonal only is
light squares are bid week is a six for
instance but it's all covered yet Bishop
on c5 now really should kill any active
plane just grab c6 now and it's an
exchange for exchange at upon from
pretty much nothing yeah why can only
try to white reason yeah all you can
resign that's really a very very little
hope here
there's no play at all so unfortunately
we don't get a new game here by tomorrow
I've got some other Grandmaster games
going Mar what's it to Mia but from is
from Amenia yeah and to 691 that's
really high really high yeah
we know that the media has really really
matter of great GM's and on the black
side this is my personal ICC nemesis
from Latvia p.m. creep warned us off or
something I cannot pronounce this cream
cream on nose off I'm yeah I've got
absolutely terrible score against him
simply cannot cannot play this guy
okay maybe ma here can can do something
as usual
it's an endgame the black player here
orgasms an endgame specialist
he plays all kinds of simplification or
simplifying lines to get the early end
games at the Play stores and games some
really really really well
yeah plus some the the typical unfair
play that you see very often on on the
Internet I mean also off the internet
but yeah this is a strange move hard to
believe that this should be good for
black I mean yeah is some unfair in the
sense that he's playing rook against
rook without bones and all kinds of
stuff on time and yeah I'm not a huge
fan of this kind of behavior
I mean easy would be considerably
weakened rating on a three point to time
control or three point three or
something it's just that you win so many
end games on time yeah what can just
take f6 now not quite sure that this
isn't a super important pawn but it is a
part
yeah the couple of strong GM's on now
but very often you don't know who they
are there is some some website which
lists the real names of some files they
are known well no this guy doesn't have
any any name and down yeah so we
continue the same game with an extra
pawn for white but doubtful madam that
you can win this yeah B 393 stuff like
this yeah but okay you extra bonus on f2
basically and this is not not so great
yeah it's better to have it than then
not but it's not not a huge thing
check
yeah I am suspect this will end in a
draw I don't think white cannot make any
real progress iam maybe I'm the only
idea now that black has played b5 would
be to play against this pawn but I don't
see really how Knight to c3 and a4 or
something but it's not at all easy yeah
I'm really not sure what white is trying
to do yeah black just offered to draw
yeah maybe you can try a for now yeah
the only slight hope to make any kind of
progress
ah-ha-ah-ha something's happening
so bishop berry King to c5 trying to win
the pawn not at all I played this move
interesting the idea being 93 and and on
97 yeah this is probably interesting
ah this this is bad our 93 I can't
covered and ER not sure maybe white had
something better could could always tape
take one of those pawns but what he
didn't do it
how let's see what happens now f5 and b5
is detected so white white will get one
of the pawns so very tricky Bishop
before now would have won the knight but
probably a draw
yeah but still be a draw that white is
down to 18 seconds oh now we've got a
new moral game but let's just check the
end of this it's just just 40 seconds
left and let's see how this ends they
are probably in a draw yeah white white
players quick enough to not lose on time
yeah well he gasps constantly offering
draws I think this is just incredible he
would play this on time for I don't know
he would never agree a draw now he's
whining for a draw
unfortunately white gave it to him he
really deserves to lose on time
this is this in this kind of fashion
because he wins like this all the time
all right so let's go back to to the
main feature I hope we got some more
games here played by him and we've got
an albuns counter gambit if you watch my
channel regularly you know that I think
this opening is just as I usually call
it nonsense
yeah probably it is not not really great
but and let's um it's of course a viable
option muddying the waters yeah now it's
a black smooth and
you can think of taking seafoam already
or continue developing but they don't
show could take safar it's not we have a
maybe rooty one and then D for some
problem yeah it's a very strong opponent
here rated in 2600 Azamat baguette off
from Uzbekistan yeah well to six on five
minute is really really good yeah what
could black do it takes the fall
nevertheless or maybe I'm not sure maybe
you can also try to uh-huh he took it
yeah I was thinking maybe Queen d7 long
castles uh-huh and then I have 5 mmm
yeah very very weird position why to
just take this pawn yeah what what's
this from a material point of view it's
equal funny enough and black handsome so
the King in the center it's not clear
where it's supposed to go but White has
also canceled long which is very unusual
in the albuns gap crazy position if
that's really Milosevic she should like
it then let's say find good moves in it
because it's really great and that we're
finding unusual unusual solutions to to
positions
like it's um very much download time
though only in two minutes and now 12
seconds left
I'm not quite sure what luck is yeah
yeah this look at him was my first idea
at least and not the idea but how to
tell I mean like it's probably mm-hmm
yeah it's not the kind of position US
has slightly black has two bishops this
is good and they have well positions on
d5 and f6 but you get across the King
only eight and if black am wood would
get like two moves like Queen d7 and
long castles then he would be great yeah
this is cool just short castle or not be
five yeah the night is now hanging why
should it go back or or here and it's
not clear that blacks King position is
so bad I mean look at look at blacks
bishops pointing at b2 and the white
king in general so it's a question if
maybe black has some has even the better
taking chances despite his missing
gee-pole and the rear porn on h5 yeah
maybe some rook to the aid now attacking
this this this night yeah it's not Wow
what's this
I simple simple this one okay nice nice
oh so what we'll get to get a piece back
this wasn't intended sure black hood
could instead of taking on effort
probably simply playing here could have
played h4 I guess just just advancing
okay and now he will lose a piece back
it's unclear probably so I'm not not
know it's probably just an exchange
I thought the strong bishops might have
something but it looks like I'm just
material down yeah just pressurizing f7
and black you want to probably just take
it rookie to rookie to also was pretty
good but this should be pin should be
very strong also
to bishops as a bit of an annoyance but
oops okay so he returned this hoping to
get rookie aid or g8 in yeah
probably this is enough but you never
know now
no black intense Bishop d4 look d2 and
also of course and this is important one
c4 breaking the connection between the
pawn and the bishop and I don't know
is this clear and clear this position
black has got counterplay c3 now now
blacks down to 30 seconds but he's got
the position is not too bad now yeah
this should be a draw like him just push
the pawns now this is slightly different
but still take an a3 and it is wrong
yeah very nicely defended it was
certainly lost her but like did a good
job here too to defend I hope they don't
learn yeah I wrong they don't engage in
this rook against rook nonsense
sometimes really played out
even among grandmasters wolf against
rook very young very weird okay so I
hope we don't have from such a long
break after this no there's not you can
look at this quickly
the
again him and VG from Hungary playing
against this ah
we got a new game this is was quick and
very strong yeah this is fun let's let's
let I need to check this
AHA this is supposed to be a women
international master Cecile fund America
I don't want to play no no sorry
CC follower from South South Africa and
okay don't want to sound sexist yeah but
there's no bloomin international master
in the world who can reach to six on the
outer pairing it's something not
possible
I need this is someone else playing
sorry don't want to sound bad or
anything but this is simply not possible
unless there's something really weird
going on there is no women intentional
master able to get 2 to 6 cm I can I
look I look this I look her up need to
check this maybe she's like 12 years old
and rated 2 3 or something but then I
take everything back but she's 25 years
old and rated 2000 alone oh I dia maybe
a boyfriend or something so it's a it's
simply not possible with 2000 rating you
don't get to choose success it's not
possible okay and while I was arguing
about this let's have a look at the game
in fact black ass abhor not if I'm not
mistaken White has compensation but it's
still upon yeah the company
of course that blacks pieces are all all
back here so what
why should have some some good common
yeah he five is a typical move opening
up the the bishop on g2 and cause you
you get material back here easily both
back having I was black having nothing
developed by the way all eyes to see if
you have entitled attached to to a name
this is really the person I mean there
was some kind of procedure to prove ID
here so this is not some guy and I don't
know Australia just picking up the name
it's a really am this some women
international master playing and then
she must be yeah a blitz demon or maybe
or boyfriend or trainer or whatever and
I really think it's impossible that it's
home okay so why term has regained upon
and it's um it's very tricky yeah I
think why should be better yet just the
the activity and it's hard to hard to
imagine that blank would black would be
good here yeah this does also some
chatting going on here during the game
where people tell that that like cannot
be the person that that's in the profile
he had always sounds a bit bad but it's
not not not a matter of of a female
player or something
mm is not possible to get two to six
something impossible
I mean 2200 or something is
is okay even if you are rated 2,000 then
you can get maybe too chewy on the auto
pairing but more is really very not
possible
yeah in the meantime
yeah White has drummed up some nice Sun
King side attack again what should be em
should be winning him it looks it looks
super dangerous I'm not able to to
calculate this out now yeah I mean
that's a pin yeah the bishop only seven
pins
yeah like under huge pressure here I
think one can just take on deform but
there's always this bishop it's free I
know not not now I wish [ __ ] free board
can take with the Queen Queen aah a
concern as a possibility this long check
them yeah now if I should drop yeah
probably just Queenie five and whiter
versus two extra pounds but rugby three
my term yeah rugby three wins before but
you attack the serve this bishop and um
yeah why should should win fairly easily
is this good very very nicely
coordinated the night only five is
obviously strong protecting the pawn
also on d3 maybe see for now toughest
toughest defense sure yellow white
widest has got everything everything
covers each other so the rock capacity
three the night capacity three and the
king is near so it's all working nicely
together and with the King on h8 it
should really be winning black is
playing without the king
yeah Knight to f6 s is deadly Queen to
Knight f6 and then group g8 stalemate is
the only slight possibility and now you
have simply no move to prevent it by
major design rook g7 er you can play one
move yeah this is this is weird this
this account here the other ratings one
minute is not good 15 minute is very
strong just a couple of games three
minute is also very strong and that's
all other in you also the the all-time
highs are very new yeah maybe if your if
you young have some detecting skills you
can try to find out who is playing on
this account
yeah we got a new game
I'm sorry for my silence I'm sorry I was
trying to find some information on
Google and this always makes me curious
then I didn't didn't find any quick
information if this woman international
bosses maybe I don't know married to
Grandma's or something
okay so I'm it's a new game here by by
Norwich and it's a fun line coming from
a Sicilian we transposed which is
supposed to - some French - position and
yeah this this Queen b6 rook air-five
led to turn right to 936 and now White
has a pawn on d6 which should be a
weakness rather than strength hard to
believe that white zone can actually
hold on to this form but this can be
tricky it's maybe not so clear-cut but
Rock d8 now can you just play what the
ADA and take the pawn some hard to see
yeah I'm not sure why not you create
then now you cannot take on the six
because it six is hanging so you can
probably prepare this I mean even king
of seven is not not to not be not not
bad probably let's say white something
and then you play King f7 and threaten
to take T six yeah I mean I mean even
without this d6 issue I mean black has a
very nice position then strong knight on
e4 you have pressure on d4 and this
setup on the Queen side with a double
beep horn and the open a file is also
nice for black as you attack this a2
upon all the time which white needs to
attend to
and yeah he's really and try to play as
I just mentioned probably a bad sign
can't work he won and now you cannot
take yeah maybe what maybe black should
really am don't care so much about the
pawn I also as mentioned what to try to
win it but maybe you can just
concentrate on your other advantages
like the week a pawn and so on like
let's say I'm mmm that's a queen a7
adjust just to put out a move
attacking a two and keeping the pressure
on deform
shouldn't be too bad just one one idea
yeah this is some really interesting
Rosa which is really taking his time in
those critical positions and yeah coming
up with an original solution g5 I
wouldn't really have considered probably
now it's not them not a clear weakness
yeah just grabbing this and now now 92
is 7 getting getting interesting
latitude 24 you can take and night
before it's your losing material yeah
you cannot take on d4 now I think and
this then might might get tricky 24 I
think what takes Knight takes Knight e4
and wins material Queen texty form maybe
there's some tricks
Queen Queen takes Queen takes Knight
takes Knight d4 Knight c2 but I cannot
account calculators really yeah now one
can take only six and probably white
white wins now this looks very dangerous
25 maybe 25 with g4 hanging at a to hang
the a to look oh it just took them oh
this is very direct
mmm this looks winning if black moves
the Queen yo yo yo
Quinn g8 is possible Quinn g8 now Quinn
yet and he is a queen checker and then
takes the Queen black resigns yeah this
is a game where if I would have played
like I would really be angry at myself
because I mean this is what is simply
outplayed here and should lose the game
simply because of a very very badly
played played opening but like didn't
find to find the right right way to
proceed
actually I'm not sure at all about f6
I'm not sure why why not rook the ATM or
not property ed not sure I think let's
let let me try and quickly - oops this
was bad what does it have the moves
no okay and this is still in there I can
try something I try to get the game back
I'm hoping I'm not I had another one
another game again this weird women
international master from South Africa
you need to yeah in the meantime she he
whatever had won two games
all right so what do we get here and
especially cough and we got the absolute
main line with another six GF 95 here
black has tools f5 and Bishop g7 both um
both main lines came out here here White
has some some choice you can you can
take on f5 Bishop d3 c3 and also the the
sacrifices on b5 are are not I'm not
sure maybe not completely refuted Bishop
takes B 509 takes before I think Bishop
takes b5 s ER as a playable sacrificial
line c3 is also interesting now black
cannot take on before because then the
sacrifice is very strong and yeah this
now leads to the the main line of this
with white playing Knight C 293 and now
they are the some setup with the g3 this
is normal
yeah all this we can put the bishop on
d3 and then C 2 V 3 possibly our over
the g3 you can play at this is Sam also
possible this hasn't been played so much
in recent times white more try to find
anything in the 995 line the more
positional line yeah blacks compensation
for having this knight on d5 staring at
him all the time are the two bishops and
the center center pawns
and generally speaking I always thought
that blacks should be okay in this kind
of position it's very hard to believe
that he should have a serious
disadvantage share me AHA this is
interesting
white um playing at at the age 7 pond
but I couldn't take the Queen II just
haven't made and yeah very complicated
now White has got very nice nights now
yeah Queen e5 probably yeah black has
very very nicely centralized pieces this
is why it's um why it's hard to believe
that black should be you should be worse
yeah black now with black can play book
g8 now I guess yeah yeah and now the g4
Knight gets lost
yeah things I think black shirt should
win this now the reason I say you will
get to two pieces for for the
Brotherhood and then the bishop has an
excellent square on e5 and this is this
is very important if you play with two
minor pieces again the rook um you need
those strong points where you can anchor
your pieces very often the rook is is
even as strong as two minor pieces of
the nomina pieces don't have any posts
where the can can be yeah can be
anchored but him the bishop is very
strong only five it supports now Bishop
D force coming also and the night can go
to d4 and so on so blacks pieces are
working together and should be stronger
than then this rook yeah Noah bf2
something F to look at five I don't know
hey they have porn looks strong it's not
not so clear however after it is on f2
how do you promote this pawn yeah f2 was
easy but terror it's not so clear now
how to proceed b5 as a threat problem
yeah yeah that this looks nice check
taking with the rook now yeah probably
Bishop c5 and then Knight e5 this is
what I meant with you need your strong
points where you can anchor your pieces
Bishop on c5 Knight only five this is
just wrong or maybe now take take the
pawns but ninety five for now I guess or
not he said I know this is strong I know
it's stronger Knight f5 III
yeah 93 and it's over jack white his
eyes yeah pretty pretty clear win here
for for black this is our thing is
interesting only even close to being a
theoretical line but here maybe a white
needs to do something else at least
actually I think 1996 I think it's a bit
true strikes me as weird but yeah
probably a bishop of seven or threatened
by most of us
yeah but clearly this is this is no good
with luck g8 this is so what white mist
probably yeah I'm so interesting game
and Oh more interesting games I think I
hope you enjoyed it I'm sorry for that
the brief delay where I didn't say
anything because I tried to find out
some background of it no for this
someone we had account yeah thanks for
watching and I'll be back soon